Social Security must balance its books
because Social Security is funded by a
trust fund that was insisted upon by FDR
and the rest of Congress the surpluses
from Social Security will used each year
to cover other expenses of the federal
government all the money God's spent and
then some leaving no money to invest in
assets to create a trust fund all of
Finance is a claim a paper claim on
assets what is real is whether or not
you'll be paid back and the US
government is good for its money and
we're lucky to have that much money in
our trust fund every lie we tell
ourselves incurs a debt to the truth
sooner or later that debt must be paid
tonight's resolution reads given Social
Security's nearly three trillion dollar
trust fund the system cannot add to the
federal deficit arguing for the
affirmative
professor Theresa chiller doochie
Theresa Theresa please come to the stage
our king for the negative will be me
so I hereby recuse myself from
moderating and hand that job over to
Reason editor-at-large Nick Gillespie
Nick please come to the stage thank you
I'm gonna keep my eye on you I told
Teresa earlier you know that you're a
home court advantage but I'm with her as
the ref that the the ref is against
Eugene so keep it clean we want to see
your hands where we can see them okay so
where many of you have been here before
this is an awkward style debate Teresa
is gonna go first
make sure if is the voting closed or
come okay so if you haven't voted go to
Soho vote calm and vote what we're gonna
close it in like 30 seconds here Therese
is going to talk for up to 15 minutes
and make her argument in favor of the
proposition jean will give 15 minutes
they'll have 5 minutes of rebuttal to
each other and then we're gonna open it
up to you guys 30 minutes of Q&A let's
have an interesting wide-ranging
conversation about Social Security
deficits and what we're gonna do to
screw over Dave Smith's kid all right
Teresa please hey I'm not the first up
Nick and Dave were the first stuff in
their negative views of Social Security
so I am here to persuade you to change
your mind so to vote for my argument
you'll be voting yes you'll be voting
YES for the affirmative which is given
Social Security's nearly three thousand
three trillion trust fund the system
cannot add to the federal deficit that's
affirmative I'm going to argue it and
you will vote for me at the end of this
time despite the eight wrong things Dave
said about Social Security another eight
in the last 30 seconds but he said
seventeen funny things so he's forgiven
Social Security can't by law and by
precedent and by culture add to the
federal deficit and the federal debt
medic
can food stamps can the unemployment
insurance fund can tax cuts can a war
with Iran can but not Social Security by
law Social Security must balance its
books because Social Security is funded
by a trust fund that was insisted upon
by FDR and the rest of Congress
Republicans and Democrats now a trust
fund funding mechanism means that the
fund collects the revenues and then pays
out the benefits but the calculations
are based on what's called an actuarial
funded standard which means that current
and projected revenue is set to equal
and it's always titrated over time to
equal projected liabilities the United
States stands alone from all other
developed and developing countries by
using a very conservative actuarial
standard it projects out 75 years rather
than the standard 35 years so at the
very beginning it was meant to pay for
itself and it was meant to do so in a
very conservative way Social Security
liabilities of course are the promised
benefits the Internet's determined by
the number of beneficiaries that's key
because that goes back to David's baby
and the amount of benefit generosity the
administrative costs are also a
liability but they're tiny it's a much
more efficient system than the 401 K and
the IRA you're suckered into having but
that's another issue
now Social Security actuaries know what
the benefit generosity is and they could
also count they count the babies that
are born and they project that within 62
to 70 years many of those babies most of
them will be collecting Social Security
benefits so the calculation of the
projected liabilities are easy the fact
that there is a baby boomer does not
faze the actuaries even though everybody
now is throwing up their hands and
saying there's a generational tsunami it
is not an issue
in the Social Security trust fund the
benefit generosity the fact that people
are living longer is also not an issue
in terms of the Social Security funding
all those were predicted and part of
this 75 year projected actuarial
standard funding it was brilliant and
responsible to pay for every promised
benefit we had a trust fund that was
quite small up into 80 from 1985 and
then thinking ahead again the Social
Security actuaries projecting ahead said
we're going to have a lot of babies we
collect your Social Security right about
now and so will advance fund for their
retirement and so taxes were raised much
more to cut then to cover current
benefits and that is why the trust fund
is now almost three trillion dollars and
why now that started about a year and a
half ago we are redeeming those bonds to
pay for retirements now I would think
that all conservatives and libertarians
would like this kind of small-bore
government program would want all of
government to be run like Social
Security you anticipate the liabilities
they're pretty small Social Security
benefits are among the small of any
development any developed country and
that you would want rules to make sure
that it pays for itself advance funding
Social Security like we did in 1984 is
like we are supposed to do to plan for
our own retirement while we work we save
we invest in the private market and then
when time comes we redeem our pension or
401ks or IRA with the assets that we
have when we reach retirement age and
for most of us a big part of our assets
are government bonds the same assets
that are in the Social Security trust
fund now currently as we said truck the
Social Security trust fund holds 2.8
trillion dollars in government bonds
thanks to this 1984 plan that means that
even though half of us don't have any
pension or a 401 K or an
arrey or any kind of retirement plan can
I repeat that half of us don't have
anything but social security we all own
some government bonds we're all
investors through the Social Security
system now through the combination of
tax revenues and earnings and principles
from the trust fund Social Security is
estimated to be solvent into 2035 so
remember that number 2035 after that if
the system doesn't get any more revenues
then or doesn't get any revenues now
starting right now the results will be
horrible Social Security will only pay
77% of promised benefits that's you me
our relatives now these will be tragic
consequences but it's stark proof that
the Social Security system can't add to
the deficit or debt because it pays for
itself now let me go a little bit deeper
when we through Social Security invest
in government bonds the government
creates an intergovernmental debt in
contrast when China buys our
governmental bonds
it creates an external debt which China
redeems its bonds US taxpayers indeed
pay them back with interest coming from
general revenues when the Social
Security Administration redeems its
bonds another part of the government
transfers assets to another part of
government it's like the $20 bill the
$20 you borrowed from your spouse this
morning the nation as your household has
the same wealth and created no debt as
it did before so because Americans buy
government debt and there's a transfer
there is no change in the debt and the
deficit so why do smart people think
wrong things like Social Security adds
to the budget deficit and debt it's
because of confused accounting and
because of politics so Dean are
sympathetic if you think Social Security
can add to the deficit in debt you've
been misled first the accounting
confusions the deficit Control Act of
1984 required that this Congressional
Budget Office that's the office the CBO
that produces outlooks for Congress it
required it to
an accounting convention that
contradicts established social security
law on practice instead of the CBO
basing their projections on current law
which show that Social Security can
create no deficit or debt the law passed
under President Reagan requires the CBO
and what it ever does when it reports to
Congress to assume that Social Security
can draw from the general budget then
that will happen in 2035 and not cut
benefits but that isn't what the law
says and that's not what will happen so
in its debt projections
it adds trillions and trillions and
trillions of dollars to the debt but
that's just an accounting mistake the
law bars Social Security from taking
from general revenues now second is the
accounting trick of the unified budget
which Jean might argue makes it look
like Social Security creates a deficit
as I said Social Security is now
redeeming Treasury bonds held in the
trust fund so we see a transfer from one
part of the government to another if
Social Security is unified in the budget
its included in the whole budget then
though it only can spend what it takes
in it looks as if the system is drawing
from general revenues but only looking
at the Social Security now here in Soho
in 2019
it looks like it's causing the deficit
but because it's cashing in its bonds
but it ignores all the other time it was
in surplus and made the deficit look a
lot smaller arguing that Social Security
is causing a deficit is just as wrong as
saying that a retiree who lives on five
thousand dollars a month
gets $100 $100 from a part-time job and
gets four thousand nine hundred dollars
from redeeming their treasury bonds in
their retirement fund is a retiree and
deficit because they earn only $100 but
spend five thousand but that household
is not living beyond its means it's not
creating a deficit or debt in modern
societies we save to pay for expenses
later now a related mistake is arguing
that since Social Security can be viewed
in the unified budget it masks the true
side size of the federal
deficit but everyone literally everyone
making decisions about spending is fully
aware of the legal and economic
relationship of Social Security in the
rest of the budget the unified budget
might create might include Social
Security trust fund on the ledger but
the Social Security deficits are not
added to the debt and therefore Social
Security trust funds don't make the
deficit either smaller or larger now
here are the politics when I told people
I was participating in this debate one
was a physics student they said really
everyone knows Social Security can't
contribute to the deficit benefits are
going to be cut if we don't raise
revenue so why are we having this debate
is it just are we having a debate this
nice Monday summer afternoon because of
the counting I suspect we're having this
debate for deeply political reasons
there it's very clear that there are
many people that want Social Security to
look bad and bad is creating deficits in
debt in an october interview the usually
careful leader of the Senate Mitch
McConnell revealed the political use of
the canard that Social Security can add
to the deficit in a TV interview he's
tried to shift attention away from the
Trump 2017 tax cuts and moved it towards
costly entitlements that's the code for
Social Security Medicare and Medicaid he
said that they were the real drivers of
the death not the tax cuts and calls for
Social Security and other entitlements
to be adjusted the demographics of the
future Republicans in particular in
particular have always aimed to cut
Social Security out of a general
ideological opposition to government
programs but the idea the argument the
proposition that Social Security as to
the deficit is wrong so in conclusion
Social Security can't add to the deficit
because it's designed
by law to be self-contained the reason
why past congresses and presidents
insisted on the actuarial based trust
fund funding first for Social Security
and then for Medicare was to create a
framework for a discipline Congress and
it worked
Social Security benefits are extremely
low benefits can't be raised to penny
without raising Social Security revenue
first and if it isn't Social Security
who and what can add to the deficit and
debt well they've already told us to be
sure it's the 2017 Trump tax cuts and
the Senate Republicans and the House
Republicans they're projected to add one
to two trillion dollars to the debt it's
about 164 billion unto the deficit large
deficits and debt will result from these
sugar-daddy of tax cuts in 2017 it's bad
policy in flush times in good economic
times like we have now to not cushion
for the bad times that's bad policy but
Social Security cushioned for the bad
times which are now people living long
and also many people retiring so
Congress can add to the deficit and debt
through every other program and tax
provision in the federal budget but not
through Social Security Social Security
is off limits every penny paid now and
in the future must be paid for every
penny paid out and every penny promised
must be paid for with money coming in
now and in the future perhaps we should
have another debate do deficits really
matter but tonight our debate as far as
I'm concerned as far as you might be
concerned and I hope you are concerned
that you'll vote for me for the
affirmative is settled
Social Security can't possibly add to
the deficit
thank you very much Teresa Aguilar
Gillard uchi and now taking the negative
proposition mr. Jean Epstein no thanks
let me begin by quoting Sir Thomas More
who said back in the sixteenth century
if the earth is flat could Parliament
make it round if it be round could the
king's command flatten it
well applying that rhetorical question
to the 21st century the earth is round
and nothing our government can do or say
can flatten it similarly even though the
government might continue to declare
that it's in possession of a nearly
three trillion dollar trust fund nothing
it can do or say can summon that trust
fund into being that's because the trust
fund doesn't exist and since there is no
trust fund the resolution fails there is
no trust fund to cover the cost of
social security any more than there was
a trust fund to cover the cost of
spending on the government's Wars since
the dollars spent on the wars can add to
the federal deficit so to condole are
spent on payouts from the Social
Security system on the surface at least
you might think that those in the know
are on Theresa's side consider the
coverage of Social Security's finances
in the Wall Street Journal which has a
reputation for grasping fiscal realities
an April 22nd story in the journal
begins by referring to the trust fund
though as though it does exist the lead
sentence reads quote Social Security's
costs are expected to exceed its income
in 2020 forcing the government to dip
into its nearly three trillion dollar
trust fund to cover benefits unquote
based on that statement it sounds as
though Teresa must be right as long as
the program is able to keep dipping into
its fund of nearly three children to
cover benefits it is indeed self-funded
and it can't be adding to
a federal deficit but as a sign of the
doublethink that plagues so many
accounts of this topic the same article
goes on to assert that Social Security
has in fact been contributing to the
deficit we read quote that rising Social
Security costs have contributed to
larger deficits that are set to exceed
one trillion a year starting in 2020
unquote notice from the wording of that
statement that Social Security will not
only contribute to the deficit in 2020
it is already been doing so the same
kind of inconsistency plagues
the nonpartisan Congressional Budget
Office which puts out reports that warn
of rising deficits and the cost of
Social Security as a major contributor
and yet it too uses the term trust fund
as though the trust fund actually exists
the reason for the glaring inconsistency
is fairly simple
these establishment sources feel
obligated to acknowledge that there is a
trust fund if the government claims
there is in but but the pretense is
dropped once they turn their attention
to the real life issue of soaring
federal deficits in similar fashion had
the king in Thomas More's time actually
declared that the world is flat
established sources would no doubt have
given due acknowledgment to the Kings
viewpoint but when it came to the
serious matter of navigating the globe
in the high seas the pretense would also
have been dropped in 2013 the fact that
the trust fund doesn't exist got exposed
for all the world to see except that few
noticed it that was when the Republican
Congress was refusing to raise the debt
limit which meant that the government
was facing difficulty paying its bills
President Obama released a warning that
if the debt limit wasn't raised Social
Security checks might not be sent out
the warning exposed an obvious fraud
wasn't there supposed to be a Social
Security trust fund and if so how could
there be any concern about sending out
the Social Security checks a trust fund
if it exists consists of assets like
stocks and bonds so if the need arose
why not just sell off some of the assets
and cover the payouts in the in that way
yet the media to Obama's warning
seriously without realizing that he was
as good as admitting that there is no
trust fund to better grasp why there is
no trust fund it helps to understand how
such a fund could have been created in
the early 1980s the baby boomers were
screaming into the labor markets and
retirees were collecting Social Security
checks and they were not so numerous the
payroll tax that is earmarked for Social
Security checks which had container
ating surpluses the surpluses could have
been invested in the stocks and bonds of
other advanced economies including bonds
issued but creditworthy foreign
governments as well as in the domestic
US market in the same way other
countries maintain sovereign wealth
funds for example the government of
Norway has a fund valued at more than 1
trillion with a portion of the assets
currently invested in high-tech stocks
in the US had these investments been
made as the surpluses came in they would
indeed have been a trust fund with real
assets and these those assets could
gradually be sold off to fund social
security this would have meant that
payouts to beneficiaries would not have
boosted federal deficits the system
would have been self-funded just as
Teresa claims it is but that's exactly
what did not happen instead the
surpluses from Social Security were used
each year to cover other expenses of the
federal government all the money got
spent and then some leaving no money to
invest in assets to create a trust fund
and at the same time an accounting fraud
had been engineered as the surpluses
were generated
bonds were created technically referred
to as general accounting series or GIS
securities matching the surpluses in the
same dollar amounts the GA s securities
have been put into the account of the
Social Security trustees the debt is
also known as intragovernmental debt
which is debt the government owes to
itself so when the Wall Street Journal
refers to the Social Security system
dipping into the trust fund to cover
benefits it is really talking about an
exercise that will only keep bureaucrats
busy here's how that exercise works to
meet its obligations the Social Security
Administration submits the GS s
securities for payment to the US
Treasury say the amount is 50 billion
these bonds are liabilities to the
Treasury just like all Treasury bonds
are that 50 billion will be an outlay of
the Treasury in the same way that the
Treasury makes any other outlay the
Treasury will cut a check to the Social
Security Administration for 50 billion
and then Social Security will use this
50 billion to cover its obligations to
its beneficiaries but obviously the
transfer of 50 billion from the Treasury
to Social Security is no different in
result from a 50 billion transfer from
the Treasury to the Pentagon or to the
agricultural department or to any other
agency of government that needs to pay
its bills and there is no trust fund for
the Pentagon or AG Department since the
fiscal result for Social Security
payouts is exactly the same the trust
fund is an accounting fiction by analogy
imagine your parents give you what they
claim to be a trust fund worth 1 million
dollars you find that instead of being a
rich kid holding 1 million in stocks and
bonds you have been given 1 trillion in
IOUs
signed by then when you object they
explain that this is intra personal debt
money they owe themselves
similar to the Treasury's
intragovernmental debt money the
government owes itself you'll be tempted
to tell them that what they call a trust
fund has funds that can't quite be
trusted of course the difference is that
your parents don't have the power to
borrow like the US government does but
if they two are living beyond their
means
then payouts to you for the IOUs in the
trust fund also add to their deficit or
imagine a private firm running its
pension fund in this same way workers
contribute to the pension fund and are
told by the firm that their surplus
contributions are being invested in
assets it then comes to light that the
company's actually spent all the
surpluses while creating IOUs against
the firm's own revenue the firm would be
criminally guilty of fraud the US
government did the same thing the main
difference being that it spent the
surpluses on its foreign wars and the
other difference being that the federal
government's criminality is exempt from
the law legal points have been made
about the fact that Social Security
holds these GS securities while agencies
like the Pentagon and the agricultural
Department don't the argument is that
the existence of these securities
guarantees the Social Security payouts
will be made while there is no such
guarantee for agencies that lack the GSS
securities so let's call these
securities legally binding memos to the
file but it makes no sense to call them
a trust fund and makes an existence of
the legal memos cannot prevent payouts
from being cut at any time the
Congressional Budget Office actually
takes pains to explain all that I've
just said in the sea bolts January
release on the 10-year budget outlook
there is a discussion of the Social
Security trust fund that pretends the
trust fund exists well at the same time
dropping the pretense quo the trust fund
is an asset for the individual program
such as Social Security but a lot but a
liability for the rest of the
the resources to redeem a trust-fund
securities and therefore pay for
benefits or other spending in some
future year must be generated through
taxes income from other governmental
sources or borrowing from the public
unquote
as the SIBO points out then redemption
of the Trust Fund securities must be
generated through taxes income from
other governmental sources or borrowing
from the public and of course that
applies to all spending by government
since all spending can only be generated
through taxes income from other
governmental sources or borrowing from
the public the see both and nods in the
legal direction but still delicately
concludes as follows quote trust funds
have an important legal meaning in that
their balances are a measure of the
amounts that the government has legal
authority to spend for certain purposes
under current law but they have little
relevance in an economic or budgetary
sense little relevance is of course a
bureaucratic euphemism for no relevance
at all in her essay in Forbes Theresa
invert inadvertently makes the C boson
point she writes quote if you are
wondering if the trust fund is real here
are facts to judge for yourself workers
do two things with their FICA taxes we
pay current benefits and we say by
buying US Treasury bonds like many
wealthy people do unquote already it is
a stretch to say that the baby boomer
has made a conscious decision to buy
those bonds have they actually been
asked they might have realized that it
was a much better idea to invest the
surpluses in outside assets to prevent
the money from being grabbed and spent
by the government but what Teresa ads
next gives the game away quote when we
threw Social Security free rights invest
in government bonds the government
creates intragovernmental debt she then
provides as a source that defines
intragovernmental debt a link to a
source and according to that source in
governmental debt is the portion of the
federal debt Oh to other agencies the
source continues by owning Treasuries
they the agencies transfer their excess
cash to the general fund where it is
spent note the source says where it is
spent not where it's invested in assets
to create a trust fund so according to
Teresa's own source and just as a Seaver
points out redemption of the trust fund
securities must be generated through
taxes income from other governmental
sources or borrowing from the public
according to a former CBO budget
director the federal government's budget
is on the road to hell the adds quote
there is no polite way to describe what
the world's largest economy has placed
itself on a trajectory that looks like a
third-world debt crisis the cost of
Social Security now account for a record
twenty three point seven percent of all
federal outlays and are due to keep
rising faster than either total federal
outlays our gross domestic product
that's why the SIBO constantly cites it
as one key reason why federal deficits
are running out of control although it's
far from the only reason Teresa and I
could talk about ways to tame the
deficit since we are both bleeding
hearts were both concerned about the
plight of the elderly who have planned
they rounded lives around elder care
entitlements including Social Security
Medicare and Medicaid but unfortunately
we're bogged down in a myth she would
still have us believe that Social
Security is playing no active role in
keeping the budget on that road to hell
but that's exactly what it has been
doing let me conclude with a quote from
the HBO miniseries Chernobyl
every lie we tell ourselves incurs a
debt to the truth sooner or later that
debt must be paid
thanks Thank You Jay Chernobyl is a is a
comedy right Chernobyl is a comedy make
sure that okay Teresa you have five
minutes to respond you can either sit or
you can stand either whatever but you
can't do both so choose wisely I haven't
heard Sir Thomas Moore as a source for
public policy since I was at Notre Dame
sure absolutely
so let's say in 1990 you inherited real
assets you got some stock from some real
companies you got $20,000 worth of Enron
stock General Motors stock you got of
stock and some real American companies
like Kmart and Montgomery Ward's but you
did not get any of those real assets
called a government bond right in 19 in
2019 which were real assets the
government bonds or stock in Enron GM
the old company Kmart in monkey Ward's
just because the asset portfolio of
Social Security is in conservative and
it's in government bonds the most
valuable asset on the planet when the
when hell really happens in the
financial sector where does everybody
including the Norwegians go they come
here and buy our bonds so we as American
have two trillion of those bonds and
they will be paid I'm reminded jr.
reminded me
of President George W Bush who went to
in his campaign his losing campaign to
privatize Social Security went to the to
the government agency that held these
bonds in there on paper it's a show in
their lockbox
another accounting metaphor an
illustration and said huh just like gene
those aren't real assets haha you're
like he does the government official is
standing there looking a little bit
nervous within five minutes Secretary
Treasury snow went out into the world
fear and said he didn't really mean it
he really didn't mean it but gene said
what George Bush said these are real
assets the world
Norwegians we really will pay them back
so what is in the trust fund is very
real at all they are contingent claim
they are claims on future generations
just like the stock in Amazon is it is
saying when I redeem this it's a bond I
will expect the money to come from
profits from workers from somewhere all
of Finance is a claim a paper claim on
assets what is real is whether or not
you'll be paid back and the US
government is good for its money and
we're lucky to have that much money in
our trust fund in terms of the deficit
it does really matter whether or not
that deficit adds the debt that will
drain your household or your nation to
pay it back if we owed all of our debt
to say China and we were obligated to
pay it back then we would drain
productivity GDP per capita would fall
but if we borrow from each other like
the Japanese have for 20 years
their debt-to-gdp ratio is beyond any
textbook definition of what is
sustainable its sustainable because they
borrow their debt is all internal just
as you borrow from your spouse perhaps
you borrowed $20,000 from your spouse
your household debt and deficit did not
change if you borrowed from the Mafia
you would have a very different position
and you might be on the road to hell is
where I'm going to close now with the
definition of real health and that would
be if the 2035 we cut Social Security
benefits which half of our population
depend on in their old age to stay in
their house there'll be more people on
the street along with Earl on David's
Street um living that way and that's
true hell not an accounting entry about
the deficit thank you Thank You Teresa I
do want to point out as somebody who was
once married and lent money to my wife
or rather I borrowed money from her it
was a lot like being borrowing money
from the Mafia but
Jane you have five minutes got a
moderator really editorialized as a lad
I don't usually go but I mean don't
count all moderation is on a biography
chain I first of all I don't I
I completely agree with Theresa that it
would have been a bad idea to invest in
in Enron obviously as Teresa knows
you've got a very good book about
retirement planning if you've bought you
know the sp500 you would have done very
well since 1990 if you'd bought the
world stock index you would have done
very well
the Norwegians are actually invested in
our high-tech stocks at the moment but
all that's all really by the way the the
point that that Teresa herself
acknowledges is that this debt is intra
governmental debt and she herself
provides a link to a source that
explains intra governmental debt what
the government owes itself and the
source
I didn't quote from the source
completely the source continues the
cruellest that she herself links to to
explain this intragovernmental debt by
owning Treasuries they the agencies
transfer their excess cash to the
general fund where it is spent I read
that already it was spent now I assume
that Teresa would have preferred a world
in which the the Social Security so
security actually would have been a
locked box to use the term of Clinton
and gore and and if they wanted they
were aiming to balance the budget they
would have bounced the budget but
instead they raided the funds and they
blew the money I would basically argue
on their Foreign Wars because you could
choose something else they would have
spent it on you know because obviously
they just spent it but the Foreign Wars
came up and they blew it and Cheney said
you know deficits don't matter so that's
what happened that's where they blew it
that's theories well so what did so then
they created this intragovernmental debt
and and the source that Teresa herself
cites
writes of course one day they will
redeem their Treasury notes for cash
that is the people holding the interest
the Social Security system will redeem
that and the federal government will
either need to raise taxes or issue more
debt to give the agencies the money they
will need again that's the way the
federal government spends money on
everything they give that when the debt
comes and they pay it
that's intragovernmental debt what the
government owes to itself and what the
government owes to itself is again what
you might owe to yourself it's not an
asset and and that's why whenever
anybody gets real as in the case of The
Wall Street Journal or the Congressional
Budget Office they they blame the Social
Security system for the rising debt
because the Social Security system is
rising so quickly I share I share
Teresa's concern about the future
I share it and then some and you know
it's not gonna be it's not gonna kill
people like Chernobyl but it is the road
to hell and in fact in fact she's
concerned about 2035 well I suggest
Teresa that you read the Congressional
Budget Office projections for the next
ten years but on the basis of plausible
assumptions they show that it's possible
that the cost of just servicing the debt
will will exceed a trillion dollars by
2028
servicing the debt but and that will be
a 15 percent of the federal budget that
the Vera budget will be spending more on
servicing the debt than it does on
so-called defense so that's when they
may start pulling the plug that that's
psychological threshold of a truly in
doubt right now it's about a little
under 400 billion a year to service the
debt but the on the basis of
conservative assumptions it could go up
to trillion by 2028 and that's at a
point where they could start cutting the
benefits in the way that they usually do
boost the inflation measure boost the
age tax more they could reduce benefits
in lots of ways so I'm concerned just as
Teresa is my contention ironically is
that by denying that the Social Security
system is contribute
to the deficit and by the way Medicaid
all the other elder care programs are
actually contributing even more it's
really the entire elder care package
that is at risk there is a danger
the federal government may pull the plug
on a lot of old people you can end
welfare as we know it potentially for 30
year olds you can't end l took your
elder care as we know it for 75 year
olds but that I fear is the direction in
which we're going and that's partly
because unfortunately regrettably
tragically people like Teresa choose to
ignore the fact that Social Security is
indeed a major problem in terms of the
federal debt all the deficit although by
the way I hasten to add that Medicaid
and Medicare are even more problematic
thanks
thank you very much Jeanne okay yeah we
are going to the audience question and
answer period so please line up on the
side of the lobby I'm going to take the
moderators prerogative and ask two quick
questions one of each Jean are you on
Social Security yes yeah and so you are
part of the problem you're adding to our
deficit by your own logic well I
actually was donating while I was
working I was donating my Social
Security check to people like you Nick
so it's like exacta bases lights they
only socially check Oliver thanks like
reason but ever since I got fired from
my job and I don't know anything from
that from the soul forum I figured I'm
devoting a lot of time and energy to
furthering what's gone but indeed I'm
probably like one of those guys who's
flying around warning people about
global warming well leaving could be the
moral good the fact that I'm a hypocrite
should not necessarily invalidate my
argument
there we go and then for Teresa I guess
and I just want to make sure of this is
your position that intragovernmental
debt is not real debt use your
microphone my position is that Social
Security is self-contained unlike the
military budget or unlike Medicaid
although you agree I mean that the money
that has been raised and that was put in
surplus has already been spent so the
government is going to have to come up
with that to replace that somewhere
that's right okay okay let's go to the
audience first question please and I
will be Epstein Ian in ask a question
don't make a statement okay thank you I
don't quite understand the question
so if Nick can you help me out Jane did
you want to quickly reprise your your
trust fund analogy instead of investing
in stocks and bonds I will stipulate for
you to be said instead of investigating
in an index fund which does generally
yield returns over 10 20 year period
they've created IO use to themselves
interpersonal intrapersonal debt okay I
got it so you would have preferred that
we that we take from the future that the
parents would have taken from the their
children by by investing in those in the
stock market and then redeeming it but
that also means that you would have to
resell those those stocks and bonds and
the either the corporation would have to
pay out of someplace so it really is
immaterial to me and to the structure of
Social Security whether or not in 1985
we started to invest in bonds government
bonds or we started to invest in this
market completely immaterial it was a
political question why they didn't okay
next question as much as I abhor a
social security and what it does to me
alas as much as Jean and I used to be
friends I have to acknowledge that
Teresa is 100% correct resolution do you
have a question or are you going to also
go a band for all seasons there might be
a soliloquy that you want to pull out oh
no no please what is the question was
simply one statement so I'd like you to
Teresa to address two issues one is the
Bugaboo of the intragovernmental debt
the Social Security trust fund it's not
per se without government it could be
considered something like China or any
other debtor and also the statement by
Obama which was brought up about not
being able to pay and what he really
meant is that America would renege on
its debts thank you really see I'll take
the Obama first even Obama can make a
mistake and in fact when we had when we
he was just you really read this
audience wrong
[Music]
even Saint Obama can make a mistake and
it was proven to be mistaken because
when we went through sequestration and
they cut every agency because of the way
Social Security is set up there were no
there were no cuts but that means the
way Social Security is set up that when
it doesn't have enough revenue coming in
benefits will be cut and that's not true
of any other other agency except for the
Highway Trust Fund and part of the
Medicare did you want to address the
second point and which was it was mental
Janice yes yes the intergovernmental
debt I feel like we're in public finance
class the fact that one agency owes
another agency the Treasury owes the US
government I mean the u.s. of Social
Security really was a device to keep
Social Security benefits in check right
that's the whole trust fund set up was a
political framework to keep Social
Security benefits in tech if we want to
raise Social Security benefits just like
if we have to like go to Congress and
fight for it if we want em so but the
economic effect what let's say we're all
economists now is very very different
then if you borrow from your spouse or
from the Mafia if it's if it's internal
national debt between each other or if
it is an external debt and that has a
very different economic effect so that's
that's good and Thompson
you're not my friend or I still love you
and and I want you to know that we've
been getting personal is evening I mean
obviously Obama knew what he was talking
about he knew of course that the you
know the media wouldn't care and of
course Social Security is the third rail
of American politics and that's of
course why away the payments were made
clearly there would have been a massive
rebellion and of course basically that
was
good thing you don't as I keep saying
you don't pull the plug on 75 year olds
and so that was good and of course they
had the political clout to make sure the
social security pants were made not
because of these bogus assets that that
they held and I guess there's you do you
agree that intragovernmental debt is a
has a different economic effect than
public debt well in Chicago coming on no
that is an accounting fraud in two
inter-government metal debt is exactly
the same as my saying that I have
intrapersonal debt I owe a trillion
dollars to myself that's an accounting
fraud there's no such thing as as assets
of debt it's it's a complete wash unlike
what you seem to have said ed I forgot
to correct you on that
look Social Security system is obviously
part of the federal government and so we
if we wiped away the intragovernmental
debt Social Security isn't the only
agency the hell's that the operations of
the budget would be exactly the same the
only difference would be this legal
argument that because you know a legal
argument that bad if I give my io u--'s
to my son that that that's kind of a
moral claim but that's that's just a
debt I owed to myself and that's clearly
clearly a wash that's clearly which
which knee would you break gene when you
collect on your own debt would you go
right right like a left leg there are
certain questions Nick puts you which I
which can't be north dad they should not
even be entertained next question please
sir well if the last question Aaron gene
love each other I'm Theresa's husband
there is so much love there is so much
love that dare speak its name in this
room tonight at so Paul's a great lady
absolutely so the issue of how the
federal government pays the debts that
it knows whether that's to China or to
Norway or to the Social Security trust
fund so far we've only focused on
cutting benefits for Social Security why
not raise revenues the deficit in 2018
84% of it can be attributed to the trope
and Bush tax cuts or is that outside I
know if that's outside the scope is the
maybe we seem to be focusing only on
solving the social security repayment
for the money that it's given to the
federal government by doing something
within that system there's lots of ways
the federal government could pay back
well that's first of all that's a very
fair question and as I said if we can
give up on the myth that Social Security
is not adding to the deficit of course
it is and when you talk about paying
China Peng whoever all I keep
emphasizing is that is that astok SIBO
itself says there's no budgetary reality
to the trust fund when the Treasury pays
Social Security it's exactly the same
transfer as when the Treasury pays the
AG department or the Pentagon or any
other agency of government it's exactly
the same operation that's why the trust
fund is an accounting fiction but
getting to your question absolutely we
could discuss this if we could talk
about revenues and expenses as the
Congressional Budget Office puts out a
whole series of programs and plans for
taming the soaring deficit the budget is
on the road to hell I will briefly say
to you that that the tax cuts imposed by
the government clearly exhausted
the deficit but had the tax cuts not
been made the deficit and the debt would
still be a very serious problem it just
would have cost phone for a few years
there's much there's many more painful
things that we have to do to tame the
debt one of those things is probably to
rethink the whole concept of a
government handout that also goes to the
rich the the only the government can
think of a charity plan to help the rich
private-sector charities just want to
target it to those who need the
government wants to give it to everybody
that's dumb
thank you next question so I was worried
there for a second because husband
almost asked my questions but I didn't
quite hear it again sir so let me see if
I can try welcome welcome
thanks Jane all right so because as I
was listening to this I got very excited
because it seems to me that Jean Epstein
is in effect advocating a tax hike and
so this is something we can get together
on because if Social Security is adding
to the deficit as you argued and if it
would be a disaster if it wasn't paid
out as you argued and if just about
anything else we could do to square that
circle would be far more controversial
than this which also seems true then
shouldn't we be lifting the cap so that
the the rich are paying their fair share
in Social Security how about have an
ending our foreign war has been I mean
I'm for it but that's good man ben is a
friend I he's a socialist I debated on
the Dave Smith a part of the problems
show just a week ago the entire
soulmates
so let's end those foreign wars first
Ben don't you think good idea
I love I don't know if it's realistic
that we're gonna end up first okay well
you're a radical socialist Ben do you
want to so so I think you and I are in
the same page about radicalism let let's
let's deal with the real problems other
government because I
if we if we hike taxes we're only going
to feed those militaristic bastards more
of the bullets that they want so I think
it'd be very unfortunate been you and I
agree like that do you have any comment
for okay next question
Thank You mrs. Geller guchi I'm trying
to understand your argument so I think
I'm going to ask a couple of maybe one
and a half question maybe one of those
so first of all to understand your legal
argument are you not saying because this
is set up by law therefore it
essentially should be off-mike so the
fact when they were accruing surpluses
that they should not have counted that
as a reduction in the federal deficit
and now when they're paying out more
than they take in they should not be but
in fact they did account it as a lesser
deficit and now they are accounting it
as a bigger deficit isn't that right and
then I want to get to 2035 because
you're saying in 2035 well the way it's
set up the benefits get reduced to
whatever the income is in any given year
yeah but then you say but we'll never
let that happen so of course the
benefits are going to be up but if
that's true isn't there gonna be a
deficit then and if we all acknowledge
but that's gonna happen the benefits are
being a crude right now
shouldn't that be accounted as part of
the debt no that's a great that's a
really good clarification and I did try
to say that in my opening statement
you know I I really think I do win the
debate because
Jeanne did swerve to talk about the
problems with the debt and the deficit I
really want to focus on the proposition
that the Social Security is treated by
by the people who collect revenue and
spend money as off budget and proof of
that is because it is off its treated as
off budget in a trust fund like a couple
of other agencies do it can only pay it
can only spend what it takes in it does
mean that in 2035 I used to think five
years ago that will never happen the
results the consequences of cutting
benefits there are just too tragic but
the closer we get to 2035 and nothing
has been done to raise taxes or to bring
in more revenues I think it might happen
it could very well happen because it
will effect actually on the bottom half
the distribution much more than the rich
so it is not axiomatic like the CBO is
required to account for that the
promised benefits now will be paid only
scheduled benefits there are promise for
scheduled benefits only benefits that
can be paid will be paid it is true that
politically now we're having this debate
about adding to the deficit because it's
redeeming as treasury bonds before when
Social Security masked the deficit that
Congress really was running it was never
put on the the budget because of the
surplus made it look like government was
being responsible so we maintain we keep
it off budget treat it that way and then
Jeanne and I and Ben and everybody else
can then debate what government should
spend and what it should tax and who
should pay for it well well I wanted to
come and thanks for the question
buddy Menten and yeah yeah and I just
want to comment that indeed what
happened was in 1998 the Clinton
administration declared that the budget
was balanced and the only reason they
were able to do that
is that they were counting the surpluses
from Social Security and so here
ironically I to reason I completely
agree starting in 1980 or thereabouts
when the but when the death when the but
when the surplus has started to be
created they should not have been
counted and then obviously the Social
Security system could have invested the
money but indeed what happened was the
government raided the surpluses and
spent the money and so that was indeed
what had it happened in the private
sector
it would have been regarded as criminal
fraud and so just as you suggest then
had that happened then then then a
balanced budget had to be achieved then
without including this pension fund and
the pension fund could have done but the
government by the way runs the federal
government runs pension funds but of
course and of course state governments
often raid their pension funds so
raiding a pension fund is a very
standard practice on the part of the
federal government and that's what
happened and so since we're doing that
right that's why it's adding to the
deficit okay next question kind of
piggybacking off that last question it
seems like you both agree that the
accounting is a fiction externally like
it's off budget externally so I guess my
question is like does this question even
matter you know K wow I mean I heard the
household like the household analogy if
the house has a net worth of a hundred
thousand the parents lend twenty
thousand of the kid who goes and spends
it they now have a net worth of eighty
thousand now the parents have an IOU of
twenty thousand to the kids but that's
internal like the net worth of the house
is still 80 thousand on the other side
if they have a hundred thousand dollars
and they lend money outside so they
actually owe external debt
twenty
their net worth is still 80,000 so from
the external perspective the account the
internal accounting is a fiction and if
you both agree on that why does this
question matter okay who wants to jump
at that you know you say that fiction
you talk like fiction like is a bad
thing it is it is a design it is
designed purposely as a trust-fund to
discipline it I said that in my opening
remark so it was contrived that it
wasn't an open-ended entitlement that
every single promise had to be had to be
paid for it was the original pay for the
economic effect of that household
analogy on the household is very very
different if you owe it externally or if
you owe it in between each other but
that is off the the point and if we're
going to be Oxford style we have to
stick to the to the resolution can
Social Security add to the deficit not
at all it can look like it depending
upon what Congress or the CBO does at
that moment either included in the
unified budget or off budget but the
behavior of Social Security is that it
can never add to the deficit no why does
it matter a young man and the reason why
it matters is that I'm sorry soon clear
that it's condescending but but all of
my young white hunk
he's wearing as baseball hat back where
it's genies laughing I think that what
toward it oh there were Theresa and I
have done it part of the problem is that
if you use about nine different
analogies to explain something and
people's heads get a little dizzy look
all that's really happening is that is
that the federal budget is out of
control it's on the road to hell it's
the core the course of servicing the
debt could rise to a trillion dollars
and so and so that will mean that it's
going broke that will mean that as one
wag said if the u.s. goes to war with
China it will have to finance
war with money it borrows from the
Chinese and and and so so that's the
reason why it matters the reason why it
matters is that there won't be any
goddamn elder care for you when you get
old because the government is going
broke that's all that's the reality it's
not like you know we're not like you
Jean we're never gonna grow up so now
we've got the signs coming up next
question please
and so I guess you kind of got the same
kind of theme that I did but I wanted to
make it a little more simple maybe come
from a different angle because it seemed
to me that a lot of what you guys are
speaking is just very very technical and
I don't think that's necessary yeah my
question for you is this if you both
agree that in order to fulfill the
benefits Center promise today we need
more money whether it's by raising the
payroll tax to make everybody whole or
if it is by breaking the law that we
have before and simply raising taxes to
do it which I suppose would be your case
of a breeze the deficit think what real
difference is there isn't that kind of
like are you gonna pay from your left
pocket or your right I think it's just
too much technicalities here I mean they
can onyx and that you're gonna pay war
no matter what okay can I ask you a
question I what if we raised your taxes
but what if we tripled the taxes we
posed on you tripled the taxes we
imposed on you I'm sorry
you would not be happy well the
Congressional Budget Office has
basically said that in effect that in
order in order to balance the budget in
order to avoid the fiscal time bomb in
order to prevent the government from
being on the road to hell it will in
effect have to triple the taxes that you
pay so I assume that if you accept my
word that that's true then you are
concerned not say I'm not well
you triple your but your taxes I think
he's arguing that the debate is actually
then how do we you know how should the
program be shrunk or something but
Teresa that's that's one solution
tripling your taxes yeah I mean I I do
want to win so I keep on going to the
technical aspect you know of the
proposition but you know we're all
really on the same page cutting social
the way Social Security is set up is
that if we don't make an affirmative
step to raise more revenue by raising
the payroll tax or expanding the base
lifting the cap then we are going to cut
benefits because Social Security is
structured not to address and I would
just throw in and no it's just
moderator getting to spout off here I
mean it's a program that was started in
1935 and then was kind of renewed under
Ronald Reagan who talked about how the
greatest achievement of his presidency
was to you know that you have reformed
and put on financial footing firm
financial footing for another generation
this horrible New Deal program that he
was arguing against in the early sixties
that you know maybe it's time that we
rethink the whole idea or what kind of
social safety net we need for older
people who are now extremely wealthy but
that's a kind of separate issue let's go
to the next question so I'm a fan of a
number of your arguments here Jean but I
do have one specific question for you a
few times you've mentioned this 20
trillion dollar debt and the eventual
trillion dollar per year payment to
service the debt but you're also arguing
that intergovernmental debt is an
accounting fraud so at least according
to the Treasury is this current analysis
that would peg our debt at right around
16 trillion well well absolutely I did
not good question I did not wanted to
get us into the swamp but I never used
that 20 trillion dollar figure they the
debt the debt owed to the public it's
the only debt that the cost of servicing
the debt is only the debt owed to the
public and you're quite correct at 16
trillion and
and the CBO's projections are all
adherent to the debt owed to the public
including over trillion dollars over to
the Chinese so you're absolutely right
but in fact that trillion-dollar debt
servicing is strictly debt owed to the
public the intragovernmental debt which
adds to that again is complete fiction
okay thank you
next question thank you this can be for
either party by the way we're only
talking about 2.8 trillion I believe I
routinely I own some bond funds and I
routinely during the year sell some bond
funds to do rebalancing of a portfolio I
will purchase some stock funds from time
to time and vice versa my question
concerning this trust fund would it be
possible do the dollars literally exist
could those 2.8 trillion dollars be used
today to purchase 2.8 trillion dollars
of stock assets thank you Jumana
absolutely could I was just on a
bipartisan Commission to examine whether
or not we should do it
it turns out that since we oh we're
going to were drawing down that debt
that investing now in stocks would it be
worth the risk
it would have been worth it maybe 15
years ago we might have gotten a higher
risk of rated risk adjusted rate of
return but since we need the liquidity
it's not worth it well let me address
you very good question I think Teresa
would agree indeed if she's consistent
with the source that she linked to that
if that were done it would mean that the
budget the Treasury would have to expend
to point a trillion dollars extra that's
what it would have to do on top of the
trillions are already spent because all
of those intragovernmental debts have to
be handed to the Treasury so the
Treasury simply does not have 2.8
trillion dollars to spare
but it would have to do is borrow 2.8
trillion that's what would have to
happen and so that's why the proposal is
a joke I would also just add the other
thing that would be terrifying is the
idea if I I think if the government goes
into the stock market then you
politicize you essentially socialize the
entire economy yeah they show final
question there's no more questions there
are no more questions the questions have
all been asked never happened to be the
toasts have all been made the wine has
all been drank we are going to now open
the voting again to you know what I
forgot I skipped ahead I missed the best
part we've got five minutes each of
final post Buttle I guess right and gene
do you go first in this or does Theresa
okay because you're negative so you have
five minutes you can sit you can stand
you can dance at least that's what I
hear you can but whichever okay so five
minutes and bring it on home alright
well I win the debate because what gene
did was worth off the debate with a very
worthy argument about how much what the
government should be spending if it's
worthy does it bring actually doesn't
make our nation richer and to invest in
Foreign Wars and to cut taxes for the
rich doesn't make us healthier smarter
more able to face the future or more
productive so that's a worthy debate but
it just isn't this one this one is about
whether or not Social Security system is
structured to cause the the us the us
nation to add to the debt the further
debt that we're going to have to raise
taxes and pay back later
by law it is structured so that it can't
pay more than it brings in now right now
it is drawing from the general Treasury
just like many of you who are redeemed
your pension funds and retirement
accounts are drawing from the Treasury
if it's all internal the economic effect
is not the same as a deficit that adds
two to the dead and that's what I
thought we were talking about today of
all the programs in the federal
government and all the decision that
Congress and the president makes about
spending Social Security is the absolute
least of it
now we can all come back another day to
argue about whether or not we should
raise taxes to pay for things that we
care about and I'd be happy to come back
to talk about raising Social Security
taxes to pay for Social Security because
that makes our nation richer if we don't
have people living on the street
etc or children have to pay for their
indebted parents directly all right so I
want to to close to say that the Social
Security system the way it's organized
you might call it a fraud or a fiction
it just happens to be the law and the
structure of our public finance the way
how it is organized has actually helped
Congress keep the deficit down it's
treated as off budget it doesn't won't
apply it's not sneaky there is it's a
very disciplined program libertarians
and conservatives who are true to the
conservative ideology would like most of
the government to be funded like Social
Security to Epistle anticipate
anticipated liabilities and make the
political case to pay for them so Social
Security does not add to the deficit it
certainly does not add to the debt and
it doesn't have the economic
consequences of a rising deficit and
debt would have thank you very much
Jean your final segment
[Applause]
well we did and I did at times and along
with Teresa mentioned other
ramifications of the problems that the
budget faces but indeed the resolution
is all about whether the Social Security
system adds to the federal deficit
Teresa has indicated has implied there's
only right-wingers who think so
well the nonpartisan Congressional
Budget Office has been it's actually
Keynesian and oriented it's been run
under President Obama it was run under
President Clinton it has in statement
after statement highlighted Social
Security as a major contributor to the
federal deficit why does the nonpartisan
organization deeply respected by all
sides keep saying that it adds to the
federal deficit well it does so because
it has responsibilities to do the
accounting of the federal government and
it has to report the truth Social
Security and now accounts for record
twenty-three point seven percent of all
federal outlays and it's due to keep
rising faster than either total federal
outlays a gross domestic product it's
really the elder care costs that are
soaring and the reason why SIBO
constantly cites bees as one as a key
reason why federal deficits are running
out of control is that those are the
parts the mandatory parts of the federal
budget that keep rising I wanted to
emphasize that by talking about this it
does not mean that I lack compassion for
the elderly who receiving Social
Security Nick himself outed me as a
Social Security recipient so I may be a
hypocrite but I obviously care about
these elder care entitlements
and the if if we got serious about those
problems then we would have the
compassion to recognize that the federal
government the federal budget being on
the road to hell probably means that if
Trump Obama Bush the 20 candidates last
by last count for the Democratic
nomination Elizabeth Warren they talk
about spending more raising taxes but
spending probably more than they could
have a tax and they have the total head
in the sand about the fact that these
endocrine entitlements are running out
of control and that and that Social
Security is causing is a key cause of
the federal deficits that are
unsustainable and what will happen what
will happen unless articulate and
thoughtful people like Teresa join us
what will happen is probably the crunch
will hit and the federal government will
start pulling the plug and it will start
ending welfare as we know it for 75 year
olds for 80 year olds that's the kind of
lack of compassion a federal the
government is capable of the same
government that raided that pension fund
for so many years and and and did not
allow those funds to be invested so
again I would only ask you to consider
if indeed the trillion dollar trust fund
is preventing Social Security from
adding to the federal deficit then why
does the non partisan partisan
Congressional Budget Office why has the
non personal
partisan Congressional Budget Office
been talking about the Social Security
as a contributor as a main contributor
to the deficit every time you open one
of its reports I submit that the
resolution fails and that you should
vote no on the resolution it does indeed
add to the federal deficits
the rest is all accounting nonsense a
matter of law is what Teresa says I will
land on my quote from Thomas More
paraphrasing them a little bit if the
King passed a law that the world is flat
would that make itself thank you very
much thank you very much now let's have
a big hand a big round of applause for
Teresa killaura Tucci and Jean Epstein
for debating this we're going to open
the vote in now so please go back to
Soho vote calm and we'll have a couple
of minutes I'll try and do some patter
you know let's you know I had a really
nice really nice lunch today that I
could talk about but instead one of the
things I'll talk about our upcoming
debates for the sohe forum on Monday
July 15th renegade university had
Thaddeus Russell he's a Columbia trained
historian will defend the resolution
post-modernism is necessary for a
politics of individual liberty against
Rockford University professor Stephen
Hicks author of explaining
post-modernism Hicks is an arch critic
sad Russell is a proponent of
post-modernism that should be great
Monday August 12th
George Celgene director of the Center
for monetary and financial alternatives
will defend the resolution bitcoin is
poorly suited to the purpose of becoming
any nation's main medium of exchange
against Safa Dean a moose author of the
Bitcoin standard the decentralized
alternative to central banking that one
is real hot ticket if you want to look
for that it's if it's not already sold
out Tuesday on September 10th part of
the problem podcast host Dave Smith our
warm-up back tonight we're still all
kind of toasty from his comedy will
defend the resolution the libertarian
party should never again put up national
candidates whose views are similar to
those of gary johnson and bill weld
against nicholas or wok who SAR work who
is the chair of the libertarian National
Committee
and then and I'll in Monday October 7th
Jacob solemn he's a reason magazine
senior editor and the author of saying
yes in defense of drug use will defend
the resolution
except for laws prohibiting the sale of
drugs to minors and driving while
impaired all laws that penalize drug
production distribution possession and
use should be abolished along with
special sin taxes on drugs and he's
going up against the former New York
Times reporter Alex Berenson author of
tell your children the truth about
marijuana mental illness Milnes illness
and violence
how many much longer do we have to two
minutes okay well you know I'm gonna go
so let me recap July 15 yeah I know but
Jean is telling people what's happening
on Sunday December 8th it just seems
like kind of a stretch all right well
you know go to the SOPA forum calm is
that soma formed org dot org the Soho
forum dot org and you can buy a VIP
package where you get a bunch of
different tickets now you get a
preferential rate you'll know you'll get
in you know that I'd say the odds are
strong that both the the post-modernism
and okay but renegade University I had
the postmodern debate the Bitcoin debate
these are gonna sell out go get a VIP
package and that way you'll make sure
you're in a Tuesday November 5th Richard
Wolffe University of mass professor of
economics emeritus will defend the
resolution socialism is preferable to
capitalism as an economic system that
promotes freedom equality and prosperity
against soho forum director Jean Epstein
guest moderator to be announced but this
is the Amherst maybe maybe I don't know
you know you court me a little bit Jean
you know it's like it's our first date
for God's sake the University of
Massachusetts Amherst is one of two
Marxist economics departments right the
other being at Notre Dame oh yeah so
this exciting okay and then Sunday
December 8th Loyola University professor
of economics Walter block will defend
the resolution while a pregnant woman
should be legally required to help the
fetus survive outside her body whenever
that is possible she retains the legal
right to evict the fetus at any time
during her pregnancy and he'll be going
up against Carrie Baldwin of the MIR
Liberty podcast so the fetal you know
that's the perfect Christmas season a
producer Scrooge will be the guest
moderator gene the essence of where you
where you come up with resolutions like
that I don't know and he picked the
fetus you know
yeah and then the last sketch of the
scheduled debates is Monday January 6
best-selling author in Silicon Valley
entrepreneur Martin Ford will defend the
resolution robotics will soon lead to
widespread joblessness underemployment
and the concentration of wealth in the
hands of a few against Anthony Sam Roffe
co-host of the Scottish liberty podcast
and author of universal basic income for
and against all right do fetuses get the
universal basic income or then they
could pay rent right they wouldn't have
to be evicted
yeah now that's true yeah they've got
rent control but nobody gets evicted
okay we are let me move over here is the
finding okay now remember given Social
Security's nearly three trillion dollar
trust fund the system cannot add to the
federal deficit Theresa was saying yes
to that the pre vote was eight point
three percent said yes they agreed with
the proposition forty four point seven
nine percent forty five percent said no
it cannot add to the deficit and
undecided was forty six forty seven
percent it can it can add no is that it
cannot
okay so the post is for the yeses went
from eight point three percent to
fifteen percent for a change in about
six point two five percent so that's in
an Teresa's favor the nose went from
forty five percent to eighty percent for
a change of thirty five percent and the
undecided went from forty six percent to
five percent so that means a gene is the
winner
[Applause]
congratulate for a very interesting
thank you all for coming plays the bar
is still open there are recent magazines
all over the place hang out a lot more
thank you for coming
[Music]